la cámara de los comunes avaló esta
noche el informe del comité de
privilegios del parlamento que
estableció que el ex Primer Ministro
Boris Johnson mintió varias veces y
deliberadamente sobre el escándalo del
partygate Aunque Johnson ya no es un
diputado porque renunció en la víspera
de la publicación de este informe lo que
quiere el parlamento de sentar un
precedente e imponerle un castigo bien
significativo en la práctica significa
entonces que Johnson no va a poder
ingresar libremente al parlamento porque
no va a tener un pase de una tarjeta que
lo acredite como es diputado que es un
hecho sin precedentes en este país el
informe también recomendaba que si
Johnson no hubiera renunciado hubiera
sido sancionado Por 90 días lo que hacía
Que prácticamente perdiera de manera
inmediata su silla en el parlamento la
votación de esta noche en la que solo
siete diputados a favor de Boris Johnson
votaron en contra del informe demuestra
además que el partido conservador su
partido del que era Prácticamente la
gran estrella estaría listo para dar un
paso y cortar con el pasado con el
pasado que representa Boris Johnson y
tener una mirada un poco más Audaz sobre
el futuro sobre las elecciones del
2024 y lo que hace que el dan añorado
regreso para Johnson en el futuro a la
política sea más que una realidad una
posibilidad muy remota el gran ausente
de Esta noche fue el actual Primer
Ministro Richie suna quien inclinó de
una u otra manera La balanza y se mostró
hoy como el verdadero líder del partido
conservador